- I've been told that I look
very eager in the profile.
- I'm looking at a crotch shot.
- I know. I'm sorry.
- That's not the kind of picture.
- Swipe left.
(edgy music)
- My name is Kelly and I'm here to get my
Tinder profile updated.
- I've been on Tinder.
I've been on Bumble.
I don't know how to start
conversations on the internet.
- My current profile
on Tinder is not great.
I even don't think it's that great.
- I feel like she'll look at my profile
and be like, "This is pretty good."
At least, that's what I hope.
- I'm ready to open
myself back up to dating.
I've been single for over a year now.
- I wanna put myself out
there and see what I can do.
- Let's do this.
- I'm Julie Spira.
I'm an online dating
expert and dating coach
and I'm going to whip some of these
online dating profiles into shape.
The good part about online dating
is there's more than
over 40 million singles
in the United States alone
that are using dating
sites and dating apps.
- Why is it so hard?
- I know. You ready to check them out?
- Mobile dating boot camp, here we go.
Okay, Ryann. So, I'm looking
at your Tinder profile
and the first thing that
I see the group shot.
- [Ryann] I know.
- [Kelly] Ryann, we talked about this.
- It's nice to know that you have a posse
but the fact is, they don't
belong in your primary shot.
Maybe it can be the sixth
photo, but not the first.
- Yeah, that's a number six.
- Oh, we've got to get
you without sunglasses.
- I'm literally always in them.
- I love that picture,
except for the sunglasses.
It's good to list vistas that
you like to go because you
need to make it easy for
somebody to ask you out.
That says, "Take me out to the ball game."
- That's also in Peru
with a baby alpaca.
- [Kelly] Why?
- [Julie] I wasn't sure
if it was a unicorn.
It's different.
- Oh no.
- That's not a compliment.
- And then the last one.
It's a pig?
- It's a pig.
- [Ryann] Yeah, it's a little piglet.
- [Julie] Is it your pig?
- [Kelly] It's just a friends.
- [Julie] Is it licking its'
tongue? What is it doing?
- [Ryann And Kelly]
It's licking its' nose.
- Oh, licking its'
nose. How sweet. I know.
But, you want a boyfriend, not a pig.
- I don't know.
- [Julie] "Not good at my bios."
Okay, I have to tell you something.
Profiles that get the
swipes left are the ones
that start off by saying,
"I'm sorry but..."
Sexuality isn't all about your body shape.
It's about walking into
a room and owning it.
This is what's great about you bio.
Right up top it says
University of Pennsylvania
and that screams, "I'm super smart."
It's a real turn on to have somebody
that can be in a boardroom and a bedroom.
And you can do both.
You ask a question in a profile
and you have more people responding to you
because they see that question mark
and they're given an instruction.
Anything that can mirror to someone else's
has a greater chance a right swipe.
- [Kelly] Okay
- [Julie] Both of you have
the same homework assignment:
That you need two new photos
to replace the two I pulled down
and you need to redo your bios
saying where you're from originally.
Think of something unique
and then ask a question.
I have a lot of hope for the two of you.
- Thank you.
- Thank you so much.
- Julie suggested that we get new photos
for our Tinder profile and...
- We're gonna try.
We're gonna try. We're gonna try.
- We'll do our best.
I just realized I already broke rule.
She said no sunglasses,
so they gotta come off.
- Red is the color of love.
There's research that backs
up that more right swipes
on people are wearing red.
- Since we couldn't find red shirts...
- We're just gonna have some fun with it.
- Yeah, we're gonna make it really fun.
- Even though I'm nervous
to meet someone new,
I'm also excited because even if
it doesn't work our romantically,
friendships are important.
- I've never been dating before,
so I think that that's the
most nerve wracking thing.
What do I say? What do I do?
What if I embarrass myself?
Kelly and I are going
to take Julie's advice
and we're about to start
messaging some boys.
- I do have to say that his
profile specifically says
that he comes from wealth.
I just think that that's
an obnoxious thing
to point out in a Tinder profile.
- Moving forward online
to get yourself offline
and on a date is imperative.
Ask them a question.
And if you can use their first name,
suddenly you personalize the experience
and you're one step further along
than a person who just says, "Hey".
- I was swiping earlier today
and I matched with this guy
and we were just texting a little bit
and just decided to go get
drinks tomorrow after work.
So, it's pretty cool.
- So, I did start swiping a little bit
and I got one Super
Like with the blue star
and the person that Super Liked me
if someone I've dated already.
Mmm, doing not great.
- You might write ten people
and only one person will write back
and that's just the way
the number game flows.
- It is like applying for jobs.
- Accept for love's supposed to be
for the rest of your life, potentially.
So, why are we not putting the
same amount of energy into our love lives?
- [Kelly] That's a good point.
- [Ryann] That's so true.
- I work a lot more I love.
So, I just matched with a guy named Max
and we've been talking a little bit
and I think I'm going
to ask him to hang out
because this is all about
putting myself out there,
so, we'll see what happens.
- I get ready, get dressed, and get ready
to go out tonight and he just texts me
about ten minutes ago.
We're about an hour away from
when we're supposed to
meet and he canceled.
It looks like I got stood up.
On the bright side of things,
I did match with another guy named Phola.
I messaged him to see if
he might wanna go out.
Kelly already found a date, too.
So, we're going to try to
turn it into a double date
and see if tomorrow night
works out better than tonight.
- My experience on Tinder and Bumble
was really just finding people
that didn't look dangerous.
And I've read a lot of
articles about things
that really haven't gone well
for people that date online.
- I convinced Kelly to go
on a double date with me.
- We're going together.
- Yeah, we're a little bit...
- But I have someone coming too.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we're gonna do a
little double date. So...
- And we're not gonna get murdered.
- Right.
- Because we have each other.
- [Ryann] Or we'll get...
- [Kelly] Or we'll both get
- [Kelly] murdered.
- [Ryann murdered together
This is Phola. Say hi.
- Hi.
- Yeah, so were on a double date actually
so Max and Kelly are also here.
- And this is Max.
- Hey guys.
- He agreed to be on camera with me.
So, good guy already.
It's nice to go with a friend
just because it's more
comfortable automatically
and I think the two guys also
had fun meeting each other.
There was no awkwardness.
If anything, it just felt
like a nice group handout.
I think Max is somehow making me nervous
because I just dropped
like half my sandwich
all over my pants.
- So we didn't get murdered.
That's always good.
Meeting Phola was awesome.
He was a really nice guy.
He was good looking and I'd like to
explore that and see where
that relationship goes.
- Having a love expert
go through my profile,
it made me feel venerable,
but it also was good
because she's not a friend
so she doesn't know me personally.
She just kind of said this
is what a stranger would see
and this is what they would think.
- I don't know if Tinder's
the best way to fall in love,
but it's definitely a great
way to meet new people
and to kinda like put yourself
out there and just try it.
- This week taught me it's okay
to be your goofy, weird self.
Somebody who's out there to Match you,
just be open to them.
- I liked online dating
because meeting people
in real life is hard.
(upbeat music)